the day before yesterday former acting
Attorney General Sally Yates testified
before a Senate panel about the Trump
Russia investigation specifically from
the angle of disgraced former national
security adviser Michael Flynn's firing
and yesterday Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey Comey led the
investigation into Lee into Hillary
Clinton's emails and was leading the
FBI's investigation into Russia's
involvement with the 2016 election
including connections between Russia and
the current president Donald Trump and
his associates Comey was three years
into a three year a ten year term a
question I received dozens of times in
the email overnight is David is it
common for presidents to fire the FBI
director the firing of an FBI director
by a president is an extremely rare
event and what's even more rare is a
sitting president interfering with an
FBI investigation that directly affects
the president by firing the FBI director
and even though Donald Trump once
praised James Comey for his leadership
during the Clinton email ordeal saying
that he had quote guts Trump is now
saying he fired Comey because of how he
handled the Clinton email investigation
and it is an absolutely and totally not
credible explanation the letter
explaining the firing is on the screen
saying I have received the attached
letters from the Attorney General and
Deputy Attorney General of the United
States
recommending your dismissal as the
director of the Federal Bureau of
Investigations I have accepted their
recommendation and you are hereby
terminated and removed from office
effective immediately
while I greatly appreciate you informing
me on three separate occasions that I am
not under investigation I nevertheless
concur with the judgment of the
Department of Justice that you are not
able to lead effectively to effectively
lead the bureau isn't that oddly out of
place in a letter firing James Comey
about over his handling of Hillary
Clinton's email scandal Trump says I'm
pleased you've informed me three times
that I'm not investigate under
investigation which is also not even
true it's not true but I think because
Comey has been
the Trump administration is under
investigation that means that Trump
thinks he's off the hook in that
situation Comey didn't receive this
letter before the news went public
call me found out that he had been fired
from a TV in the back of the room at a
speech he was giving in Los Angeles
which is similar to Sally ate Sally
Yates found out she was being fired by
Trump through the media as well and uh
it none of this makes any sense
whatsoever
the New York Times and CNN are saying
yeah the Department of Justice was told
to come up with a justification for
firing James Comey more than a week ago
and Trump is trying to communicate to
the American public I'm not under
investigation the firing has nothing to
do with the Trump Russia investigation
Kellyanne Conway who we haven't seen for
a while showed up on CNN last night with
Anderson Cooper totally delusional
appearance echoing the same totally non
credible talking points and the the
recommendation was from Jeff Sessions
and the Deputy Attorney General I don't
understand Pat why if the the Clinton
investing nothing new has happened with
the Clinton investigation since
inauguration day meaning that if that's
the reason that Comey is being fired
they had all the same reasons On January
20th to fire Comey but they didn't which
makes it incredibly hard to believe that
this is the reason they're firing Comey
especially because as you said Trump and
sessions have praised Comey for how he
handled the Clinton email investigation
yet so I think that leaves two possible
reasons one Trump is upset that Comey
wouldn't verify his claim that Obama
wiretapped am sure the other one is that
he has something on Trump when it comes
to the Trump investigation and he's
worried yeah and that's sort of the
obvious conclusion anybody would come to
there's another aspect to this which is
the letter says that this was based on
the recommendation of Attorney General
Jeff Sessions and the Deputy Attorney
General jeff Sessions
said he would recuse himself from
anything related to the Trump Russia
investigation isn't recommending the
firing of the guy running the Trump
Russia investigation being involved with
the Trump Russia investigation Trump is
getting backlash over this from
Democrats
Republicans Republican congressman
Justin a mash of Michigan tweeted
yesterday my staff and I are reviewing
legislation to establish an independent
commission on Russia the second
paragraph of this letter is bizarre
Republican Senator Jeff Flake of Arizona
tweeted I've spent the last several
hours trying to find an acceptable
rationale for the timing of commis
firing I just can't do it
Senator John McCain Republican chairman
of the Armed Services Committee said he
was disappointed in Trump's decision and
repeated that we need a special
congressional committee to look into
what is going on right before firing
coaming Trump brought congressional
leaders to the White House to tell them
that he was firing Comey reportedly
Chuck Schumer Democratic senator from
New York told Trump this was a quote big
mistake and frump responded okay we'll
see FBI a commis deputy and former FBI
officer Andrew McCabe is now the Acting
Director Trump may very well try to
replace Comey with an FBI director that
might influence the Russia investigation
in a way that's favorable to Trump Rudy
Giuliani is one name that's been floated
this is having an immediate impact James
Comey was scheduled to testify tomorrow
about the Trump Russia investigation
that's not going to happen
can we get just one one fair and full
investigation into Trump Russia the
house investigation was was a total
abortion the guy running at Devon Nunez
was running to the White House to tell
Trump what they had
now James Comey is fired and he's no
longer going to testify in this
investigation in the Senate
investigation I just want one fair
investigation Pat yeah it's very
upsetting because the FBI is ideally in
a political organization well certainly
more so than the House and Senate
investigation or a fee and we don't know
of course at this point who Trump is
going to replace call me with yet but
whether it's Rudy Giuliani or Chris
Christie or trey Gowdy
it's going to be a Republican hack the
obvious explanation here as you were
pointing out is that the FBI was getting
way closer than Trump wanted to finding
things out with regard to Trump Russia
the explanation we received is bogus
whether it's Gowdy or Christie or
Giuliani or whoever that
ultimately in there this reeks of
desperation it's reminiscent actually of
Richard Nixon Saturday night massacre
the Saturday night massacre was a point
in the Watergate scandal when Richard
Nixon former president ordered the
firing of Watergate special prosecutor
Archibald Cox and attorney general
Richard Elliot Richardson and his deputy
William Ruckelshaus resigned rather than
complying with the order Cox was
eventually fired by the US Solicitor
General but as we now know pat it all
blew up from there and there's many
journalists and historians who are
saying this is feeling like that point
in the Watergate scandal well if there's
a lesson from the Saturday night
massacre is that that didn't work and
ultimately information came out about
the Watergate scandal the cover-up was
revealed and Nixon got taken down my